Is my last meal in Germany.
I requested having some German schnitzel,
and luckily everyone else was on board.
We had a big family dinner at this little German restaurant.
Lucky was in a silly, goofy mood today,
which was probably all his excitement about the German food.
My sister came, my parents,
my brother, and I didn't even have to look at the menu.
I knew exactly what I was gonna eat.
They were so kind to bring lucky out.
An English menu, had an alcohol free beer,
and I had one of my favourite drinks,
which is a malt beer. Before we all ordered our food,
lucky and I had to get the, uh,
schnitzel. Doesn't like mushrooms,
so I got those. And we got a few other things on this side as well.
Because I knew that that food wouldn't be enough for.
Lucky. Also needed an obscene amount of lemons for his schnitzel.
This food always hits the spot for me.
I didn't love the salad. My dad ate it.
And I tried some of my mom's steak.
This is a Frankfurt classic herb sauce,
so I dip my fries in it. Before I could even get through my meal,
lucky was already onto the next schnitzel.
We had about three before we all wanted something sweet.
So we got some red current ice cream,
chocolate pudding, Kaiser schman,
which is a deconstructed pancake.
Then it was time for us to go pack our bags.